BRUNO OLIVEIRA: My name is Bruno
Oliveira, and I work
with Android Developer
Relations.
TOM WILSON: Hi.
I'm Tom.
I'm an engineer on the Google
Play Services Team.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And we're going
to talk to you about
some advanced games topics.
Actually, we couldn't reveal
that before, but our session
is actually about advanced games
topics using Google Play
game services, of course.
So for this talk, we're going to
assume that you went to the
other talks and that you already
know all the basics.
Of course, I'm not talking
about this BASIC.
I'm talking about
these basics.
So you should be able
to set up your game.
You should be able to
create a client ID.
You should be able to write the
sign-in flow, basic stuff
like achievements, leaderboards,
and then set up
a multiplayer game as well.
So we're not going to cover
any of those basics.
Now, we're going to talk about
a few topics that go beyond a
basic game.
We're going to talk about some
of the things that real games
often need.
So GamesClient is great.
I love it.
For simple games, it's
all you'll need.
But real games often have a
need to use PlusClient and
AppStateClient as well and
manage all three of them in a
way that makes sense.
Now, real games have
players that deeply
care about their progress.
So I pick up my game, and then
I spend countless hours
battling monsters, solving
mazes, collecting loot.
Eventually, my Level 1000
Fighter Wizard Cleric Board
can survive pretty much anything
in the known universe
except a phone upgrade
that kills them.
So real games have players that
deeply care about that
kind of thing, which is why real
games need Cloud Save,
not just simple Cloud Save,
but you need to deal with
Cloud Save conflicts in a way
that makes sense and doesn't
lose any progress
for your users.
Also, real games often use
native code, which, as we
know, is pretty simple, right?
And nothing ever, ever
goes wrong with that.
Real games often need a lot
more, like custom UIs.
They need to do advanced
automatching.
They need to integrate with
third party engines.
Which is why we're going to
structure this talk around
nine tips for real games.
Actually, they're not exactly
tips because these are not
things that you necessarily
have to implement.
Let's call them, say,
information quanta?
TOM WILSON: That's
a little wordy.
How about something simple
like how tos?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: How tos.
How to's better, so that's
a good idea.
So onto the first how to, which
is useful for games and,
I think, life.
TOM WILSON: Unfortunately, we
can only teach you it for
games, not for life
in general.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Anyway,
so, what's that?
TOM WILSON: It's the universally
accepted
representation of a user.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Of course,
naturally.
Fortunately, I write
code better than I
draw pictures, naturally.
So some games manage to
accomplish a very unique feat,
which is to annoy the players
on the very first screen.
That's actually pretty
impressive.
You can show one screen
and you can
annoy most of the players.
How does that happen?
One sure way to make sure that
that's going to happen is if
the player starts your game,
doesn't even know what the
game is about, and what they see
is an annoying pop-up that
might say something like that.
Maybe not exactly with
those words, but
that's what they mean.
You either sign into my game
or you get out of my game
because you have to sign in.
So that's not a very good
experience for the user
because maybe I don't even know
what the game is about.
A slightly less annoying
variation is games that don't
really require me to sign in,
but then they spam me every
time I start the game with a
pop-up asking me if I want to
sign in or not.
And then maybe I don't even know
what the game is about
yet, but then I keep getting
spammed every
time I start the game.
So why should I click
that if I don't know
what the game is about?
Compare that to this more
friendly game experience that
offers, but doesn't force,
the option to sign in.
Notice that it also explains to
the user what it means to
sign in in the context
of the game.
And if I still don't feel like
signing into the game, I can
play Single Player, and that's
still going to be fine.
Now, I'm eventually convinced
that I want to sign into this
particular game, and then the
game clarifies that I'm signed
in and gives me an option to
sign out, so I'm in control of
the sign-in.
And then it enables some
additional functionality like
Multiplayer, Achievements
and High Scores.
So at the very least, any calls
to the game's API in
your code should be protected
by that check.
So if the game's client
is connected,
you call the method.
If it's not, you do something
else, but
at least don't crash.
And of course, if you want to
implement that well behaved
sign-in flow, you need to make
sure that you don't show a
pop-up unless the user actually
clicks the Sign-In
button, because it's very
annoying to see a pop-up when
you didn't ask for it.
To do this, it's important to
keep in mind that calling
connect won't actually
show a pop-up.
There's no pop-up if
you call connect.
So you can call it safely
from onStart.
Now, where the pop-up might
show is when you try to
resolve a connection result.
This may show a pop-up, so you
only want to do that if the
user clicked the
Sign-In button.
This is how you might
implement this.
You have a Boolean flag
indicating whether or not the
user has clicked the Sign-In
button, and then you use that
flag to decide what to do with
a connection failure.
So when you get a connection
failure, you see, did the user
request sign in?
If they did, then it can show
that pop-up dialog.
That's OK, because they
requested it.
If they didn't, then you store
that result for later.
When the user eventually clicks
the Sign-In button,
then you check if there's a
pending connection result from
the previous step.
And if there is, you
try to resolve it.
And if not, you set that
flag to true and
then attempt to connect.
And I think that's pretty much
it if you only have a
GamesClient.
But, Tom, what happens if
they have something more
complicated using, say,
GamesClient, PlusClient,
AppStateClient?
What happens in that case?
TOM WILSON: It's funny that you
ask because our next topic
is exactly that.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Oh.
What a coincidence.
TOM WILSON: What are
the odds, right?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's almost
like we planned this.
TOM WILSON: Yeah, somehow.
So we've talked in the basic
talks about how you use a
single Google Play
services client.
Let's quickly recap what
that looks like.
You've got your onCreate method,
then you have your
onStart, where you connect
to the GamesClient.
If you get an
onConnectionFailed, then you
resolve your problems.
onConnected, you're
ready to go.
And then finally, an onStop,
you disconnect.
So if you've got multiple
clients when you get created,
go ahead and create all the
clients that you want, and
then add them to an array
so that you can
keep track of them.
Now you just start connecting
your clients in order.
Connecting an already connected
client is totally safe.
There's nothing else you need
to worry about there, so you
just don't need any extra
error checking.
If you encounter a failure while
connecting, you just
resolve it the way you
normally would.
Most of the time, that's going
to involve launching some sort
of intent to get a result back,
and then once you get
the result, you just continue
connecting clients.
If a client's already connected
and you call connect
on it, you'll get the
onConnected callback.
So in this callback, all you
have to do is loop through it
looking for the first
nonconnected client and then
repeat the process.
Once they're all connected,
you're good to go.
Finally, in onStop, all you have
to do is disconnect all
of your clients.
That'll tear down all the
state, make sure that
everything's good, release
all the resources.
Different clients that you're
going to be using ask for
different permissions because
they're accessing
different user data.
So if you just do the default
thing we just showed you
above, this is what your game's
going to look like.
You're going to see
a Sign-In button.
The user clicks it, they'll
see a pop-up.
And then they'll see another
pop-up, and then, eventually,
they're going to make
it to your game.
That's going to make your
users look like this.
It's not a really
good experience.
So how do we do better
than that?
To avoid this, when you create
your clients, you just request
all of the scopes that
you need all at once.
So when you build every client,
you just pass in all
of the scopes that you want to
use, and that's going to turn
this nightmarish multi-pop-up
scenario into this.
It just consolidates them down
into one, which will make your
users look like this.
So if you want some examples,
you can look
at our sample code.
We've released this
with the SDK.
We have a GamesHelper class and
a BaseGameActivity class
that use all three clients--
Games, Plus, and AppState-- so
that you can check it out and
see how this works.
So that's how you can use
multiple clients.
But now that the users are in
your game, let's talk a little
bit about actually giving them
something fun to do.
Bruno's going to talk about how
to use the Games APIs from
our favorite place,
native code.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So until now,
we've been pretty much safely
tucked inside the cozy virtual
machine, but it's time to step
out in that exciting world
where many games live.
And that's, of course, the
world of native code.
Nothing against Dalvik.
Virtual machines are just
great, but when I first
learned how to use
NativeActivity,
I was really excited.
It was like, yay, C, C++.
And then I realized there
was stuff that I needed
to do in Java, too.
Fortunately, there is JNI,
which, as we know, is pretty
simple and straightforward.
So I call FindClass and then
I get my JavaClass and
everything should work, right?
TOM WILSON: This always works.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: This
always works.
And then, of course, I am met
with sadness because I see a
ClassNotFoundException.
And after digging a lot, that
happens because that thing
right there doesn't really have
a clue about my classes.
It knows about the framework
classes.
So if I'm trying to instantiate
the framework
class, that's fine, but my
classes, it doesn't really
know anything about.
There is a solution which
involves getting a different
class loader and so on, but
here's a method that's often
easier for native
applications.
If I derive my class from
the frameworks standard
NativeActivity, I can add some
convenience methods to it,
which I can then call from
native code without any need
to deal with class loaders and
any funny business like that.
So I just load my shared library
like this, as usual,
and then I write a convenience
method in my derived activity
class, which I'll call
from native code.
In this example, this
convenience method is calling
GamesClient.submitScore, and
then I'm going to call that
from native code.
How do I do that?
This is how I do it
from native code.
I just get the object and then
get the method using the
method name and signature,
and then call using
CallVoidMethod.
So that calls my convenience
method.
TOM WILSON: That just seems
too easy, Bruno.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's
too easy, right?
Well, if you ever feel that
anything looks too easy or too
simple, just add a different
thread into it.
So as you know, multithreading
is very complicated.
It is my opinion that if the
world ends one day, it's going
to be because of a raised
condition somewhere.
[LAUGHTER]
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So what
about threading?
So native code often runs
outside of the main thread.
That's even the default if
you're using NativeActivity.
So what happens if you
accidentally make a method
call that should have been done
on the UI thread from
that separate thread?
What's going to happen is that
maybe your app is going to--
maybe it's going to work.
And that's terrible, because
then you don't notice the bug.
But maybe your app is going
to behave in some bizarre,
strange way.
Maybe it's going to go up in
flames, leaving you only this
mysterious error
message behind.
That, of course, is a very clear
message except that it's
in log speak.
And logs are very friendly
creatures.
They are, in fact, the
developer's best friend, but
they just have trouble
expressing themselves sometimes.
In log culture, this message
really means,
"I really like you.
But you are on the wrong
thread." So if you see that
message, that means there's
nothing wrong, you're just
calling that method from
the wrong thread.
You should be careful to call
that from the correct thread.
In these cases, you can use
the off-thread developer's
best friend, which is?
TOM WILSON: Got to be
their dog, right?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: The dog?
Well, close.
It's runOnUiThread.
TOM WILSON: And this
is why Bruno is a
DevRel, not an artist.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
So summarizing, your native code
calls your Java method
via JNI, and then that method
calls runOnUiThread,
specifying runnable.
And when that runnable runs, of
course, that's going to be
on the UI thread.
Then you finally invoke the
Games API and everything
should work.
So this is what your convenience
method probably
looks like.
This method can be called from
any thread because it makes
sure that this inner part only
happens on the UI thread.
You can even call this from the
UI thread itself because
runOnUiThread is safe to call
from the UI thread itself.
So now that we've talked about
threads, let's talk about
another interesting topic,
which is the border.
As you know, the border can
be a very dangerous place.
One hears lots of stories
about the border.
I'm, of course, talking about
the border between Dalvik and
native code.
So there are many frightening
stories about data structures
that try to cross, don't quite
make it to the other side.
They fall prey to bands of stray
pointers, and they wind
up in the craziest
places of memory.
And there are stories of
shipments that end up having
to be copied every single time
in what are very, very slow
smuggling operations.
And then there are even cases
where things are so
uncivilized around the border
that the garbage collector has
to do a lot of work to pick up
the debris that your code
leaves behind, which is why
we're going to give you some
quick travel tips to ensure
that you have a safe and
speedy journey down to
the native border.
First of all is travel light.
Avoid copying tons
of data back and
forth across the border.
Remember that copies can happen
where you least expect.
So for instance, even that code
that looks innocent, you
might actually be copying the
whole 128K managed buffer
twice in that code, maybe even
three times, and that's all
because you want to access
four bytes out of it.
Because when you call
GetByteArrayElements, you
might be making a copy, and
when you call Release, you
might be making another copy.
A much more economical way to do
that would be just to call
GetByteArrayRegion, and then
just get the bytes that you
need out of it.
Also, pack the right buffers.
That's very important.
Remember that managed byte
buffers are very fast to
access on Dalvik but may be
very slow on native code.
On the other hand, if you're
going to do most of your byte
work in native code, then
you should probably use
allocateDirect to get a direct
buffer because that's going to
be fast on native, but
maybe it's going
to be slow on Dalvik.
There's no solution that's
fast and fast.
You have to choose your buffers
carefully depending on
where you're going to
do most of the work.
Also, don't engage in
race conditions.
You might have heard about
They are a dangerous local sport
around the border, and
they're not for tourists.
So if you're sharing buffers
between native thread and
native code, make sure you
use the correct locking.
Sometimes you can even
call GamesClient
from different threads.
But be careful not to call
from two threads
at any given time.
So use some smart locking
to make sure that
that doesn't happen.
And last but not least, don't
keep stuff that's not yours.
That's frowned upon.
I'm talking about Dalvik
references, of course.
So just because you got one
through a method call, it
doesn't mean you
get to keep it.
If you want to make a local
reference global and keep it
forever and ever, you need to
ask JNI and you need to ask
JNI nicely.
So what's the magic word?
TOM WILSON: Please, right?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Well,
close to that.
It's NewGlobalRef.
So NewGlobalRef is the magic
word that you use on JNI if
you want to keep something that
it has passed to you.
Now that we've talked about
all this native code stuff
that's pretty much down on the
ground, let's take a break and
go back to the sky.
Let's talk about Cloud Save.
You know, like cloud, sky?
TOM WILSON: Cloud.
Sky.
Got it.
Very clever, Bruno.
So for those of you who were in
some of the previous talks
today, we talked a little bit
about the Cloud Save features
we're releasing.
You could save your game in the
cloud, load it again later
on another device.
It's pretty cool, right?
But sometimes you have to
deal with conflicts.
This might happen if the user's
playing on multiple
devices or if they play while
they're offline and then come
back online later.
We're going to walk through
how that works in a little
more detail.
As a quick refresher, if you're
going to use the App
State APIs, you have to make
sure your app is actually
configured to use them.
So you go to the Google API
console and turn on the Google
Play App State API
bit as seen here.
If you've already configured
your game through the Play
console by using the other
Games features,
you're already set up.
Everything's good to go.
There are three main APIs that
you'll want to use on the
AppStateClient.
The first is loadState.
You call this to actually load
the most recent state from the
cloud onto your device.
The next is updateState, and
you can call this to, well,
update the state of your data.
This form does a lazy update.
It just schedules the update
to happen whenever we next
sync to the cloud.
There's another form that
you can call with an
updateStateImmediate that
updates the state immediately.
You might be sensing a
pattern with some of
these method names.
Finally, there's resolveState.
This is the API that you call
when you actually want to
resolve a conflict, and
it's what we're
going to focus on here.
As you saw in the previous
slide, whenever you actually
load state, the first argument
you pass in is an
OnStateLoadedListener.
This is an interface that
has two methods.
The first is onStateLoaded, and
that's what we call in the
normal case where everything's
working perfectly.
The second callback is
onStateConflict, and that's
what happens when our SDK
detects that there's been a
conflict somewhere
in your data.
It gives you back the data
that's stored locally as well
as the data that's
on the cloud.
So to help illustrate what's
actually going on here, we're
going to talk about my
favorite new game.
It's this totally rad, totally
awesome new game, and it's
called "Pick a Color." It's
going to be the next number
one hit on the Play
Store, I'm sure.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Awesome game.
TOM WILSON: So when we talked
in the introduction talk, we
mentioned that each write
to the server is
associated with a version.
The way we deal with detecting
conflicts is to separate our
storage on the device
into two areas.
We have one for the local state
and one for the latest
we know from the server.
We also maintain a dirty bit
to help indicate whether or
not the local data's
been modified.
So let's walk through what
happens if I'm actually
playing "Pick a Color." I pick
blue as my favorite color, and
that writes locally that
my data is blue and
then marks it as dirty.
Now we're going to sync, send
that up to the server, and
that associates a new version
from the server of ABC.
When that returns to the device
and says, hey, success,
it's going to mark that the data
is no longer dirty and
store ABC as the current
version.
Now if I choose yellow, I'm
going to write locally that
the data is yellow and
mark it as dirty.
So what's going to happen if
my device goes offline now?
Well, it still knows about the
data that I'm holding, it
still has all that state
locally, and so the next time
it comes online, it's going
to try to sync.
But what's going to happen?
Let's imagine that we've got
someone else who's got a
separate device and has randomly
chosen their favorite
color to be green.
I'm going to come back online,
and now I don't know what's
going to happen, right?
There's going to be something
weird here.
So when I actually call load
state, I'm going to get called
back in to pick a color with the
onStateConflict callback.
We'll have local data as yellow,
server data as green,
and the version that it returns
to us is the latest
from the server which is
DEF, in this case.
So how can "Pick a
Color" actually
resolve this conflict?
You've got colors, right?
They don't merge very well.
So maybe it's just going
to ask me to pick my
new favorite color.
I'm a typical user and, of
course, that means I'm always
consistent.
So now I've changed my
mind and red is my
new favorite color.
So it's going to call
resolveState with data red and
version DEF, which updates the
local data and the version.
We send that to the server.
The server now has a new version
in the cloud, and when
it calls us back with success,
we mark that the data is no
longer dirty and update
our records.
There we go.
The conflict's resolved.
So the resolveState API takes
in new data that you want to
pass up to the server.
You're supposed to pass the best
data for your users, but
how do you know what
the best data is?
That's going to depend
on your game.
You could just take the most
recent from the server-- maybe
newest is best--
or you could prompt the
user, kind of like
"Pick a Color" did.
But in general, you're going
to want to do something a
little bit better than that.
If you store some data in your
state, you could actually do a
Smart Merge and figure out how
to actually get the user into
the best possible state.
Let's take a look from
another sample game.
This is our other
favorite game.
It's called--
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's even better
than "Pick a Color."
TOM WILSON: I don't
know about that.
It exists, so maybe
it's better.
But this is one of the sample
games that we actually
released with the platform.
You can see it's a really,
very exciting game.
It's got a bunch of worlds, a
bunch of levels, lots of deep,
engaging gameplay.
And to play this game, it's
really, really hard, but you
basically click on a level and
it asks you how many stars you
got, and then it gives
you that many stars.
It's really hard.
This is what our savedState
for that game looks like.
It's really just a map that says
how many stars I got on
each level.
So if I have a conflict between
this state on the left
and this state on the right,
which one of them is best?
Well, we don't really
know, right?
I got different numbers of stars
on a different subset of
levels in each one.
It was really hard to
get all those stars.
It took me a lot of hard work
and a lot of pain, so I really
don't want to lose those.
So the right way to do this
would be for a game to build a
combined map that actually takes
in the keys from both
and then in the case of
collision between the keys,
takes the highest value.
Pretty simple.
On each level, give me the best
number of stars that I
possibly got.
The overall takeaway here, you
have to figure out the right
thing to do for your game in
order to avoid losing progress
for your users.
So hopefully that gives you a
little bit of insight into how
we handle conflicts in the SDK,
what kinds of things you
should do with your game to
actually handle this.
Most of the example games we
used here are pretty basic--
I mean, "Pick a Color" and
"CollectAllTheStars" are
awesome, but they're not
the most state of
the art games ever.
Bruno, do you have any advice
for people who actually want
to make fancier, more exciting,
more graphically
intense games?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Sure.
I know that after
"CollectAllTheStars" and "Pick
a Color," that sets the bar
pretty high for games.
But even though it sets the bar
pretty high, you can still
make good games after that.
TOM WILSON: You can do better.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah,
you can do better.
So let's talk about third
party engines.
Now, there are exceptions, of
course, but most nontrivial
games are probably going
to want to use an
engine of some sort.
You've been down this
road before.
We're all developers.
You started thinking, well,
engines are for
lazy people, right?
And then, man, this
shader stuff is
actually kind of hard.
And then wait, we can actually
make it work if we just render
everything backwards three
times and then flip the
y-axis, and that doesn't work.
And then, we're never going
to ship this thing.
OK, let's use an engine.
So you've been down
this road before.
So there are two kinds of
engines, the ones that you
have control of and then you can
call them from your code,
and this other type that works
in the reverse order.
In this case, you don't
call the engine.
The engine is going
to call you.
The first type is trivial
because it's no different from
integrating with any other
application, so we're going to
focus on the second kind, which
can be more challenging.
So the first thing you have to
figure out in your engine is
where it's hiding
AndroidManifest.xml.
It's definitely hiding that
somewhere because if it
produces an Android APK, it has
to hide that somewhere.
So there should be an easy way
to override it or add extra
stuff into it.
TOM WILSON: If there isn't, it's
seriously time to find a
new engine.
That's kind of important.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Because
if you can't override
AndroidManifest, there's
a whole bunch of
things you can't do.
So once you figure out where
your engine is hiding that,
then you have to add some
things into it.
Particularly, you have to make
sure that the Games Metadata
tag is there.
And of course, if you use Cloud
Save, you have to also
make sure that the Cloud Save
metadata is also there, which
looks just like that one except
it says AppState.
Also remember that this is a
resource reference, so you
also have to add that resource
somehow in the engine.
That's usually done through
an XML file.
Now, you usually have two parts,
which is the platform
independent code, which might
be some game scripting
language, and then you have the
platform dependent code.
So you have to figure out where
to put the platform
dependent code in your engine.
So that's going to vary from
engine to engine, but usually,
when we're talking about the
Android platform, that
typically means just
dropping a JAR file
somewhere in the engine.
And then there's going to be
a way through which you can
access the JAR from your
platform independent code.
Some engines have easy
integrations with Java.
If it doesn't, then you may
have to resort to JNI.
But either way, you can
access your JAR file.
Now it's time to set
up your activity.
If you can directly subclass
BaseGameActivity, that's the
best case scenario because
BaseGameActivity implements
the whole sign-in
cycle for you.
If you can't do that, we're
going to talk about next.
But BaseGameActivity
is available
on the Samples Package.
Now, if you can't for
some reason subclass
BaseGameActivity, don't worry.
Not all is lost because you
can still use GameHelper.
Actually, BaseGameActivity is
a pretty lazy class because
it's just really a wraparound
GameHelper.
So if you can't use
BaseGameActivity, you can
still use GameHelper,
which actually
does most of the work.
BaseGameActivity just takes
the credit for it.
Now, specifically, you have to
hook up onStart, onStop, and
onActivityResult on your
Activities Life Cycle into
GameHelper.
Then you have to call
onUserInitiatedSignIn whenever
the user clicks the
Sign-In button.
Of course, the Sign-In button is
up to you to implement, so
it might be a rotating,
floating, 3D Sign-In button,
or even 4D.
When the user clicks that, you
call onUserInitiatedSignIn to
begin the sign-in process, and
then you have to listen for
the sign-in callbacks, which
notify you when the sign-in
has succeeded or failed.
So usually hooking up onStart
and onStop are not really a
problem because most engines
have good equivalents for that
because those are pretty common
life cycle methods.
Now, you might have a problem
with onActivityResult.
That can be more troublesome
because if your engine doesn't
give me access to that, well
then, there's really only one
thing left to do, which is you
have to override your engine's
base activity and then update
your AndroidManifest to
reflect that.
So you find out what your
engine's base activity is,
then override, make your own
activity base on that, and
then override onActivityResult.
Also, remember what
we mentioned
about threads before.
If you're sure that your engine
always calls everything
on the UI thread, that's
no problem.
Don't worry about anything.
If you're using any thread
that's different from the UI
thread, remember to use the
off-thread developer's best
friend, which is, of course,
runOnUiThread, just to be safe.
Summarizing, whenever the Games
API wants to talk to
your code, it's going to invoke
your platform-dependent
code, which includes the
GameHelper, and then your game
logic is going to be notified
through the listeners that you
installed on GameHelper.
If you go the other way--
suppose you want to call
the Games API--
then you call your
platform-dependent code, and
then you post a runnable to the
UI thread, and then on the
UI thread-- that's all on your
platform-dependent code, of course.
Then that runnable's going to
call GameHelper, and then
GameHelper is going to make
the Games API call.
Now, I know that this looks
complicated, but it actually
looks more complicated
than it actually is.
And to show you that this is
not just theory, we've
actually made a demo
integration, and we published
that at that URL.
So that's already live, so feel
free to download that and
take a look at that game.
So now your immersive,
nightmarish, 3D zombie game is
all fully integrated
with our API.
Now since you're putting all
this work to make sure that
you have this awesome, immersive
experience, you
probably want to make sure
that you don't break that
atmosphere by showing screens
that have nothing to do with
zombies at all.
So how do you do that?
TOM WILSON: Well, we provided
a lot of really cool UI
widgets in our SDK for you,
but sometimes those aren't
right for your game.
Sometimes they don't have the
right style, they don't have
the right theme.
They don't really look right.
It's OK.
We're not going to be
offended if you
don't like our UI style.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Much.
TOM WILSON: Much.
Maybe a little.
But you can actually write
your own custom UIs.
So this is "Nostalgic Racer."
It's a little sample game that
Bruno wrote to test out
some of our platform.
Wait.
Actually, hang on.
It says right here that I'm
supposed to wait for the
audience to ooh and aah.
Audience?
Ooh.
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
Aah.
TOM WILSON: There we go.
All right, cool.
Only a little bit of prompting
for that one.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's got
square wheels, which is
actually how physics used
to work in the '80s.
TOM WILSON: Right.
Square wheels, giant
pixels everywhere.
It's really cool,
really retro.
But here's the problem.
Here's our standard
leaderboard UI.
It's slick, it's high res, but
"Nostalgic Racer" isn't really
either of those.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's neither
of those things.
TOM WILSON: It doesn't
really fit.
So instead, we wrote a little
custom widget here that's,
well, more nostalgic, keeps the
users in that vibe, keeps
it all going.
So in order to let you build
these experiences, we made
sure that we had a Raw Data API
for all of our features--
achievements, leaderboards,
players,
invitations, et cetera.
It was a really important design
principle for us when
we were building all of our
widgets that anything we
wanted had to be built on
APIs that were available
as part of the SDK.
Otherwise, we're kind of
cheating, and that's not cool.
So how do you use these APIs?
Here's an example using
our Leaderboard APIs.
And there's obviously a lot
more and a lot more
documentation available
online.
But in this case, you create a
listener, then you call one of
our score loading methods.
This one in particular is
asking for the window of
scores around the current player
on the All Time Social
Leaderboard, so the best scores
from your friends.
Once the scores are loaded,
you'll get the
onLeaderboardScoresLoaded
callback, and that'll give you
back the actual data
that you want.
The statusCode here tells you
what happened during the load.
So if it's OK, it means
you've got new data,
everything's great.
If it's something else, you'll
read the documentation and see
what to do in that case, and
then you actually get the
actual data for your scores.
Our API provides data in the
form of data buffers, which
are kind of like lists.
You iterate through them and
grab the data you want and
bind it to your views.
So that's great.
It lets you put together all
these awesome lists of data.
But just remember that
leaderboards
don't have to be boring.
Just because we're giving you an
API that looks like a list
of scores and names and numbers,
that's not what you
have to build.
You can build something
really cool.
As an example of this-- you saw
this during the keynote--
but this was a really cool
integration from our friends
at 2D Boy for their game "World
of Goo." The clouds
represent your friends, and then
you can kind of see your
own cloud moving around as you
up and down your tower.
It shows you the scores, but
it shows you them in an
in-game, really interesting,
really fun way.
So we're really excited to see
what kind of stuff you guys
can do with this and what kind
of cool games we're going to
get out of this.
We've talked a little bit about
building custom UIs, but
let's switch gears a little bit
here and talk about some
of our actual UI widgets.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So who likes
to wait for stuff?
TOM WILSON: I do.
Totally.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Waiting
is awesome.
So when you start a multiplayer
game, you have to
wait for your friends to join.
I mean, that's just life.
TOM WILSON: I don't know.
I don't think people are
actually that happy when
they're waiting, unless
they're me.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Oh yeah,
that's true.
Pretty soon, the users are
going to be like that if
they're waiting.
And then they're going
to go like that, and
nobody wants that.
So how can you make
that better?
TOM WILSON: I mean, besides
faster friends?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah, besides
getting faster friends and
unfriending the slow ones.
That too.
But even if you can't get faster
friends, you should at
least show a waiting screen
that's not that boring.
How do you do that?
So for instance, with
something like this.
This is our built-in Waiting
Room UI that you get for free
with our API.
So it actually gives me a
sense of progress as I'm
waiting for the game.
It shows me which participants
have joined, which ones are
invited, and so on and so forth,
so I have a general
sense of the progress as
the connection happens.
So to launch it, first of all,
you have to decide what's the
minimum number of players that
you need to start the game in
a way that makes sense.
In this simple example, we're
just using int max because
this means everybody.
We want to wait for everybody
to join to start the game.
And then what I do is I get a
getRealTimeWaitingRoomIntent
from the GamesClient, and then
I launch that intent.
And notice that I should do that
both from onRoomCreated
and onRoomJoined because those
are the two ways in which you
can find yourself in a room.
You either create a room or
you're joining a room that
already exists.
So on those two callbacks,
you create the waiting
room just like that.
Now eventually, the waiting
room is going to get
dismissed, and when that
happens, that's going to
happen for one of
three reasons.
First of all is if you get
Activity.RESULT_OK.
This means that the Waiting Room
was dismissed because the
game can start.
This happens when everybody's
connected and you can start
right away.
If the user specifically asks
to leave the room from the
Waiting Room UI, you're going
to get RESULT_LEFT_ROOM.
In this case, you should
leave the room.
Remember that the Waiting Room
UI is nothing but that.
It's a UI.
So it doesn't actually leave
the room for you.
You actually have to write the
code that leaves the room
there, which is just one line.
And then, of course, what might
have happened is that
the user dismissed the waiting
room, pressing the Back button
or the Up button.
In this case, the actual meaning
of that is pretty much
up to your game.
You might want to make that the
same as leaving the room,
or you might just want to
minimize the Waiting Room UI
and keep that going in the
background, however you wish.
So that's going to depend
on your game.
Now, it's important to realize
that when you're showing the
waiting room, if you don't
specify int max and you
specify an actual number of
players that the game can
start with-- say, for
example, two--
then if that is smaller than the
number of players that are
actually playing, what may
happen is that the players may
hit a button that's called
Start Early.
So whenever you have that number
of participants, the
Start Early button is going
to be enabled on the UI.
In that case, be aware that not
everybody is going to hit
that button at the same time.
Suppose that I invited four
players and I have three, so
it's more than enough to start
the game because the minimum
is two, and then one of them
clicks the Start Early button.
The other ones are not going
to realize that unless you
implement that.
So it's very important that you
send a real time message
to the other participants
saying, hey, we're
starting the game.
And then when you get the real
time message that we are
starting early, you finish the
waiting room, you dismiss it
from the screen, and then
start the game.
Now, after the waiting room goes
away, the game starts.
Yay!
But wait a second.
That's not the game that
I signed up for.
I wanted to play a cooperative
game, and suddenly, I'm
surprised that everyone's
killing everybody.
So what's happening?
I think I just got automatched
into the wrong type of game.
So, Tom, how can I stop
that from happening?
TOM WILSON: Well, fortunately,
we thought about this a little
when we were building
this SDK.
We gave you this concept
called a match variant.
So what's a variant?
It's just a number that helps
identify what particular type
of game you want to play.
If your game supports multiple
game modes, you're probably
going to want to use something
like variants.
The contract with variants is
that when we assemble the
matches on the server, only
participants who request the
same variant will be
matched together.
That way the people who want
to play "Capture the Flag"
aren't super surprised when
everybody starts running
around playing "Deathmatch" and
shooting them in the face.
That's not a good experience
for your users.
How do you actually use these?
Well, first thing you do is
you declare a constant.
A variant can be any integer
between 1 and 1023.
We figured we wanted
to give you a
reasonable number of them.
When the user wants to start a
new automatch game, you just
create a room config with
the appropriate variant
and create a room.
There you go.
So this is a user that's going
to go into the automatch queue
for a deathmatch game.
In general, you use the variants
to split your players
into separate pools so that you
can match them only within
their pool.
This is great.
You can divide your users into
as many as you want, but don't
go totally crazy.
Different variants can't match
together, so the more variants
you use, the smaller the pool
of players that can match in
each pool is going to be.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: That's
also good advice for
games and for life.
TOM WILSON: [LAUGHS]
So if you have a million users
and you use a million
different variants, well, then
each user's off waiting in
their own individual pool and
they're never going to find
anyone to play with,
and that's not fun.
Sometimes you're going to need
to make changes to your game
that aren't compatible with
previous versions.
This is another way that you
can use variants to help
protect yourself from that.
If Version Two of your game
doesn't know how to talk to
Version One of your game, users
of these two versions
are going to see something
that looks like this.
So I'm in the game, I push
Quick Match, then
I see Please Wait.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Or our Waiting
Room UI, of course.
TOM WILSON: Even better.
Oh cool!
Someone joined.
Now I'm getting ready
to play the game.
All right, get ready.
This is going to
be so awesome.
Oh my god, this game's
going to be rocking.
Oh.
Whoops.
Right.
Not really a great experience.
So the long and short here is
if you can be backwards
compatible, obviously,
you should be.
Sometimes you can't, so
you just use variants.
If Version One and Version Two
use different variants, then
users won't get automatched
together and get that bad
incompatible experience.
We're near the end
of our time here.
You guys are well on your way
to becoming masters of using
this API, but we've got one more
thing to talk about, and
it's every multiplayer
developer's favorite topic.
Let's talk a little
bit about sockets.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: All
right, last one.
Sockets.
Yay, sockets.
Who likes sockets?
So as you know, I don't think
I have to tell anyone what
sockets are.
You just push things on one
side, they come out the other
side, that's it.
So if they are reliable sockets,
there's a guarantee
that that's going to happen,
but that's not
how our sockets work.
Our sockets are a form of
unreliable messaging.
It's like a UDP socket.
So this means that you push
things on one side and on the
other side, they might be
missing or they may arrive in
a different order.
So this is how our
sockets work.
So why would you want
to use sockets?
For three main reasons.
First of all, you might be
trying to reuse some existing
code or an engine that
relies on sockets.
You might decide that your game
logic makes more sense if
you have stream-like objects
where you can push bytes on
one side and pull bytes
on the other side.
Or maybe you're just sending and
receiving a lot of stuff
from native code and you don't
want to incur that cost of a
Dalvik call every time you want
to send a packet, so you
just have a native file
descriptor to use for that.
So to enable sockets, all you
have to do is call this during
room setup.
So remember RoomConfig is how
you configure the room?
You just enable socket
communications based on your
RoomConfig, and that's going
to enable sockets.
Also, if you enable sockets, you
can't use the high level
UnreliableRealTimeMessage.
You have to choose either
one or the other.
Can't have both.
So to get a real time socket
for a participant, you call
guess what?
It's another one of those
intuitive API names, which is
getRealTimeSocke
tForParticipant.
That gives you a real time
socket for that particular
participant.
And then you can get the input
stream and output stream from
that as well.
And from that point on, it's
just a regular input stream
and output stream.
You can push bytes on one
side and pull bytes
on the other side.
Now, of course, sockets are
a form of unreliable
communication, so it's very
important to understand how
packets may be lost
on the stream.
So if I write "lorem" and then I
write "ipsum" on one side of
the socket, you might just get
"lorem ipsum" on the other
side if you're lucky.
Maybe you're just going to get
"lorem," maybe you're going to
get "ipsum." Maybe if you're on
a particularly unlucky day,
you're going to get zip,
nothing at all.
And then remember you might also
get "ipsum lorem" because
your ordering is
not guaranteed.
It usually arrives in order,
but it's not guaranteed.
However, what we do guarantee
that you will not get is a
truncated packet, and we do
guarantee that you're not
going to get a corrupted
packet.
Because we do guarantee that if
the packet arrives on the
other side, it's going to be
exactly as it was sent.
Also remember that there are
no built-in delimiters.
So you're going to have to
figure out a way to tell when
your packets begin and end, or
just put a special character
or length field or
something else.
Because if you write ABCD and
then EFGH on one side, you're
going to get this string on
the other side and you're
going to have to tell where
they begin and end.
And if you want to access the
socket from native code, it's
actually very easy to
get a native file
descriptor from that.
You just call
getParcelFileDescriptor and
then you call getFd, and that
gives you a perfectly good
integer file descriptor to
use from native code.
So I'm calling my native method,
and of course, like
any reasonable person, once I
get a file descriptor, I write
the digits of pi into it.
So this is just native code.
That write is just a standard,
plain vanilla, write system
call that I'm calling with that
file descriptor to write
bytes into it.
All right.
Well, we've talked about a
whole bunch of things.
So from friendly sign-in, we
talked about Cloud Save.
We talked about a
whole bunch of
multiplayer topics, actually.
We talked about how to integrate
with game engines.
We even talked about the
exciting world of sockets and
match variants.
So we hope that these small bits
of information are going
to help you refine your game and
make sure that it provides
the best possible
user experience.
The reason I hope for that is
because players nowadays are
very, very demanding, and your
quality control can't
be just like that.
Actually, we've seen worse.
TOM WILSON: We've seen worse.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: We've seen some
quality control that's
kind of like that.
[LAUGHTER]
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Anyway, that
doesn't really work for games.
Games have to be really, really
awesome because there's
a lot of competition out there
for the user's attention.
So unless your game
is awesome, it
doesn't stand a chance.
So what we hope to do with the
Google Play Game Services API
is we want to take the boring
stuff out of the way.
We want to take care of all that
boring automatching and
message transport stuff so that
you can focus on what
makes your game really,
really awesome.
So thank you very much for
coming to our talk, and
remember to rate our session.
If you want to praise us or
throw your virtual tomatoes,
you can rate the session using
either the QR code or the
Google I/O App.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]